c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche relevé l'échelle allez
c'est parti mon genou roger lonjou cette
fort allez s'il vous plaît sortait le
feu sortait un peu gilles voilà voilà
faites ce que vous dites monsieur et
tout se passera bien vous êtes tous
monsieur il est parti est parti de
monsieur gilles à taux de change il
dirige 12 m
vous êtes syrie aussi je vous aime merci
j alors j'ai l'on va allumer la mèche du
canot en [ __ ] [ __ ] j'ai l'aube a
allumé la mèche du calen sayan est
allumée gilles vous allez partir dans un
instant à tout jamais plateau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]